au bout de la nuit les billets passeront
demain en main plusieurs milliards de
dollars par an le tourisme sexuel est de
loin la première source de devise de la
Thaïlande et je comprends mieux
maintenant le calme qui règne dans ses
ruelles c'est bon pour les affaires
d'ailleurs la police veille au grain
[Musique]
10 ans 10 ans que je n'étais pas revenu
à Bangkok je me souvenais de la chaleur
des épices et des klaxons je me
souvenais d'une ville tapissée
d'autoroute
par la fenêtre du taxi on dirait que le
béton a encore gagné du terrain
Bangkok citez des anges en thaïlandais
mais surtout paradis des voitures
10 millions d'habitants 12 peut-être les
statistiques ont du mal à suivre la
ville pousse dans tous les sens et aussi
vers le haut
[Musique]
ici les architectes n'ont pas le vertige
mais pour le touriste c'est un choc la
Venise de l'Asie a des aires de Tokyo
les bidonvilles en plus
[Musique]
j'embarque pour un petit tour sur les
canaux Bangkok et les pieds dans l'eau
avec ici et là des bouts de cartes
postales coincées entre deux immeubles
[Musique]
sur place ou à emporter et si ici
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
bizarre en tout cas comme cette mégapole
me donne une sensation de sécurité et
les gruyante mais rassurante
[Musique]
pour voir l'envers du décor il suffit de
dépenser 25 centimes de roue 10 bah
c'est le prix d'un journal
[Applaudissements]
voici le Daily News 40 pages et de la
couleur pour notre œil d'occidentale il
y a deux grosses surprises cet alphabet
mystérieux enroulé comme une liane et
puis ceci des photos coup de poing
assassinat la une le voici l'envers du
décor
le pays du sourire à la gâchette facile
quand le sang coule les médias sont là
ils ne cachent rien impensable en France
[Musique]
cette violence en dit long et son
traitement par la presse aussi
pendant mon séjour je ne vais
m'intéresser cofidivers les pages
sanglantes mais aussi les chiens écrasés
deux journalistes me serviront de guide
de renards habitués à chasser le fait
divers
[Musique]
toi journaliste et photographe pour la
presse écrite
et non pas donc pour la télévision un
sacré baroudeur
[Musique]
avec eux je passerai à la morgue
rencontrer la star des médecins légistes
porn type une célébrité en Thaïlande
j'irai m'aventurer dans les quartiers
chauds avec John un célèbre auteur de
polar
j'écouterai les anecdotes de jamelon le
ramasseur de mort ou de Pong pattes le
général de la police
[Musique]
je verrai en action des commandos
antigang et des brigades de bons
[Musique]
les faits divers seront mon passeport
pour comprendre la Thaïlande
[Musique]
rendez-vous avec la rédaction du Daily
News avec 800 000 exemplaires c'est le
deuxième tirage du pays
la devise du fondateur éduquée en
informant
donner du sens ou bien des sensations
aujourd'hui le Daily News carbure aussi
au fait divers
conférence de rédaction il est 10 heures
du matin l'info du jour est un peu
crapoteuse
aujourd'hui la une c'est l'arrestation
de hop un ancien candidat de la Star
Academy il a été pris en flagrant délit
de voyeurisme dans une station d'essence
il mettait une fille aux toilettes
demain ce petit scandale sera oublié
chassé par un autre
ce n'est pas comme l'affaire défaitus le
fait divers de l'année 2010
novembre 2000 sacs plastiques alignés
dans un temple à l'intérieur des fœtus
décomposés une vision macabre qui depuis
reste dans tous les esprits
[Musique]
l'opinion publique veut connaître les
derniers rebondissements
[Musique]
ça a fait les gros titres ici en
novembre dernier
qui suit l'affaire pour le Daily News
le temple de paille Guern se serait bien
passé de cette publicité pour dissuader
les curieux un bon the filtre l'accès
sans carte de police ou de presse
impossible de s'approcher du crématorium
alors c'est ici qu'ils ont été
découverts
c'est ici qu'on a trouvé donc tous les
bébés c'est ça
oui c'est ici que les fœtus ont été
découverts là-bas dans les box 9 10 et
en temps normal ces box abritent pour
quelques jours les corps des défunts
avant leur création selon le rite
bouddhiste
[Musique]
retour en novembre depuis plusieurs
jours les voisins du temple se
plaignaient d'odeur nausées à bond la
police fait ouvrir la mort et découvre
2000 de foetus emballés comme des
paquets dans du papier journal
certains sont là depuis plus d'un an
pour eux ni crémation ni sépulture
comme si ces foetus étaient enveloppés
de honte et de secrets
[Musique]
pourquoi
toi m'explique que l'avortement est
illégal en Thaïlande et qu'il n'y a pas
de tolérance
les tailles qui se font prendre sont
envoyées en prison jusqu'à 3 ans la
justice à la main lourde
voilà pourquoi les fœtus ont été
dissimulés à la va-vite
qui sont-elles ces femmes ayant du
avorter dans la clandestinité
le soir venu je vais rencontrer l'une
d'elles
[Musique]
rendez-vous dans un quartier populaire
au nord de Bangkok
[Musique]
appelons-la Wendy elle n'a que 21 ans
elle a bien voulu répondre à mes
questions
la condition masque et son visage
pendant l'interview son nouveau
boyfriend se défoule sur un
punching-ball
avec lui Wendy a retrouvé l'envie de
faire un enfant
avec mon copain à l'époque
donc j'ai décidé d'aller me faire
avorter dans une clinique de soukoun
vite
les gens savent où sont les cliniques
même si c'est illégal
[Musique]
ils m'ont donné un ticket et j'ai
attendu
de m'allonger sur le dos
tige et on tournait pendant 10 secondes
si ça avait duré plus longtemps je
n'aurais pas tenu j'ai eu très mal
ça a duré combien de temps
ça n'a pris que 30 minutes tout compris
ça m'a coûté 1800 bahts ce n'est pas un
prix très élevé on peut facilement le
payer
comme je suis bouddhiste je pense que
l'avortement est un péché
mais je devais le faire
tu aimes bien réglé ou les femmes
avortent à la chaîne
[Musique]
une rapide recherche me le confirme plus
de 400000 femmes avortent chaque année
en Thaïlande deux fois plus qu'en France
pour une population
identique mais alors si l'avortement est
si fréquent pourquoi un tel scandale à
la découverte des fœtus
peut-être justement parce que cette
découverte mettait sur la place publique
un secret de polichinelle
peut-être parce que ces petits sacs de
plastique empêchaient de détourner le
regard
les pouvoirs publics vont-ils mettre fin
à l'hypocrisie et légaliser l'avortement
pas sûr le gouvernement a même le projet
de durcir la législation
j'ai entendu dire qu'il y a une loi qui
est en discussion en ce moment au
gouvernement ici en Thaïlande au sujet
de l'avortement
il existe une loi contre l'avortement
mais elle ne punit pas le garçon
le gouvernement a donc décidé de changer
cela
il voudrait faire voter une nouvelle loi
pour inculper aussi le garçon
en tout cas les médias n'ont pas fini
avec cette affaire et moi non plus je
reviendrai plusieurs fois dans ce temple
la journée du reporter Toa continue
il m'emmène avec lui et nous nous
retrouvons tout de suite bloqué par choc
contre pare-choc
Bangkok et congestionné du matin au soir
24h/24 comme ça on est sûr d'être sur le
coup et d'être les premiers à voir les
infos
à Bangkok un journaliste de faits divers
n'a pas de bureau mais une voiture on y
travaille on y mange on y dort
à l'autre bout de cet embouteillage
monstre voici nos Padoue lui aussi passe
près de 8 heures par jour en voiture
mais c'est pour la télévision
avec son équipe il est toujours en
marotte pour ne pas rater le moindre
fait divers il a le droit de faire ce
qui serait interdit en France
on écoute en permanence la fréquence de
la police quand il se passe quelque
chose et qu'on est coincé dans les
embouteillages le cameraman prend une
moto taxi pour arriver le plus vite
possible
ce matin
la circulation est devenue fluide et ça
tombe bien la radio de la police vient
de lancer une alerte
vas-y point droit et puis on va faire
demi-tour sur le pont
là on vient de nous signaler qu'une
vache perdue sans doute paniquée à
foncer sur les gens
apparemment on lui a administré un
sédatif pour qu'elle se calme
on va voir si on peut arriver à temps
pour faire un sujet pour le JT de ce
soir
c'est là que c'était réfugié la vache
après plusieurs jours des rangs sur le
bitume
les habitants nous ont appelé pour nous
dire qu'une vache était tombée d'un
camion
si on la laisse et réussir elle pourrait
causer des dégâts ou des accidents et
d'où vient-elle elle devait être dans un
camion
on ne sait pas bien un taxi de la
percuté et puis elle s'est mise à courir
personne n'a déclaré de vache perdus
petit fait divers mais insolite car
cette vache n'est pas seulement rescapée
de la route
elle a été percutée par un taxi elle a
été blessée et partie se cacher dans les
buissons
une dizaine d'humains aux petits soins
pansement pour la corne et piqûre de
calmant
[Musique]
c'est cette solidarité
de tous ces gens pour soigner cette
vache
[Musique]
on ne tue pas un animal
bien sûr on mange de la viande mais on
ne tue que quand c'est nécessaire
c'est une bonne action
[Musique]
c'est que cette vache a sauvé sa peau en
tombant d'un camion et maintenant elle
mérite de vivre
cette mascotte de 500 kg vient de se
faire adopter
c'est ce monsieur qui va la prendre dans
son étable
pendant ce temps le caméraman de nopadon
met son nom sur les cassettes
de la vache que je viens de tourner moi
une moto de Chanel 3 va venir les
chercher pour que le sujet soit monté
voici au moins un fait divers qui fait
sourire et qui se termine bien
à 41 ans nos Paddon en a elasud d'autres
c'est un vieux briscard
[Musique]
j'ai vu des explosions des crimes des
suicides c'est vrai que ça ne m'affecte
plus
mais je suis aussi un être humain comme
tout le monde je suis parfois triste ou
joyeux
je dois mettre mes émotions de côté
[Musique]
ça y est dehors le coursier est arrivé
il emmène les cassettes au montage
et son équipe repartent eux vers un
autre fait divers je les reverrai plus
tard
je prends un tuktuk un de ces
triporteurs coloré et pétaradents
direction le siège de Chanel 3 c'est la
plus grosse chaîne privée du pays et
c'est là que travaillent pas donc
l'un des patrons me fait les honneurs de
la rédaction
la première vue ça ressemble à n'importe
quelle chaîne de télévision dans le
monde
quelques petits détails près
[Musique]
et voici la journaliste qui s'occupe du
palais
ici personne ne plaisante avec la
famille royale c'est le ciment du pays
mais ce qui m'intéresse ce sont les
faits divers les crime news en anglais
et où sont les faits divers
il y a personne aujourd'hui ils sont
tous sur le terrain
donc il y a beaucoup de crimes en ce
moment
c'est parce que vous ne pouvez pas faire
ce métier en restant au bureau vous
savez
voici le responsable des crèmes news le
fait divers qui va mettre à la une ce
soir ces produits sur la route
mais ce n'est pas notre histoire de
vache
aujourd'hui ce sera l'histoire d'un
homme blessé par balle sur l'autoroute
regardez ce sont les images du sujet
décidément il y a beaucoup de choses qui
se passent sur la route en Thaïlande le
fait divers du jour remonte en fait à
une semaine
c'est la reconstitution qui a lieu
aujourd'hui
l'agresseur est en survêtement noir
enchaîné à sa voiture
en le détache un instant pour qu'il
puisse mimer le tir ou plutôt les tirs
l'homme a fait feu à 7 reprises sur la
voiture qui le précèdent et qui
l'empêchait de doubler
à l'intérieur de cette voiture un pilote
de ligne de la taille Airways en
uniforme qui allait prendre son service
à l'aéroport
miraculeusement il va réchapper aux 7
balles mais son avion ne décollera pas
il est blessé le voici à l'hôpital
est-ce que ce genre d'incident montre
que notre société se dégrade
il y a déjà un bon bout de temps qu'elle
a commencé à se dégrader
c'est le caractère oui oui les tailles
sont trop impatients ils revendiquent
leurs droits mais ils empiète aussi sur
ceux des autres
ils sont égoïstes
rarement on a vu victime plus philosophe
de retour à l'hôtel je vois passer le
reportage au grand journal du soir
victime souriante agression brutale et
médias omniprésents voici un cocktail
inattendu
et je ne suis pas au bout de mes
surprises
[Applaudissements]
8h le lendemain matin dernier détail
pour une mise en scène dans la forêt de
caméra celle de nopadon le reporter de
Chanel 3
comme chaque semaine la police de
Bangkok exhibe une brochette d'accusé
cet homme aurait tué deux personnes ses
deux voisins auraient trafiqué de la
drogue en bout de table un petit poisson
un voleur à l'arraché
et c'est un commissaire divisionnaire
qui donne les pedigree
cet homme a été arrêté pour trafic de
drogue le mois dernier
qu'on lui a laissé cet arme en dépôt en
échange de drogue
font la foule avec son micro et va même
tenter une interview sur le champ le
présumé voleur de portable lui répond
menottes au poignet et sourire aux
lèvres
qu'est-ce que tu as fait le portable tu
as volé un téléphone qu'est-ce que tu
fais comme boulot
pâtissier
les défenseurs du droit à l'image
auraient de quoi s'étrangler
ces hommes n'ont pas été jugés mais pour
la police et pour la télévision c'est
tout comme
à la presse mais là comme ils ont
reconnu les faits c'est difficile pour
eux de refuser
cette manière de les montrer peut aussi
permettre à d'autres victimes
éventuelles de les reconnaître et
pourquoi pas de porter plainte
là où certains verrai une séance
d'humiliation collective ne pas donc ne
voit qu'un innocent appel à témoin
cette fois-ci son reportage est monté
sur place la camionnette de Chanel 3 est
garée sur le trottoir
ce qui me passionne dans ce boulot c'est
que chaque jour est différent
c'est un métier créatif
je rencontre plein de monde de l'homme
de la rue au ministre
les chaînes
et si on veut être meilleur que les
autres il faut rapporter des exclus
absolument
et des exclus nos Paddon on a déjà
quelques unes à son palmarès
le voici avec un foulard violet sur un
hors-bord des douanes il a pu embarquer
pour une opération dangereuse
[Musique]
le commando est à la poursuite d'un
bateau pirate dans le détroit de Malacca
ils arrivent quelques minutes trop tard
[Musique]
sur la plage une cargaison de cigarettes
de contrebande les pirates ont juste eu
le temps de les décharger
[Musique]
depuis le commandant nimite est devenu
un ami aujourd'hui il a donné
rendez-vous à nopadon devant le bâtiment
des douanes
privilège la voiture de la télé à même
sa place réservée
limite à un scoop pour Chanel 3 un scoop
qui tient dans ce petit camion bâché
officiellement il n'y a là que des
caisses de fruits et légumes
comment vous avez repéré que ce n'était
pas une camionnette ordinaire
à cause du poids on s'en est doutait
elle était trop lourde
pour la photo souvenir tout le monde
attend le grand patron le voici
on dévoile le poteau rose deux rangées
de cagettes et dessous une citerne en
acier
à l'intérieur 3000 litres d'essence
les contrebandiers ont fait le plein en
Malaisie pas de taxe et un beau bénéfice
à la revente
je ne sais pas j'étais juste payé pour
conduire
le conducteur du camion a une défense
aussi improbable que sa coiffure il
risque la prise en ferme
j'apprendrai plus tard qu'il sentira
avec une lourde
[Musique]
en Thaïlande les douaniers en 3000 km de
côte et près de 5000 km de frontières
terrestre à surveiller
[Musique]
quels sont les marchandises qui font
l'objet de trafic
vous avez la contrefaçon le carburant
l'alcool et aussi la drogue bien sûr
illustration avec les prises des
derniers mois
sur le territoire
il y a 150 cartons de 12 bouteilles de
whisky
l'alcool est interdit par la religion
bouddhiste
donc pour que les gens n'ont consomment
pas trop le gouvernement taxe l'alcool
et le tabac
en Malaisie ce n'est qu'à 20 minutes de
la frontière avec la Thaïlande
donc beaucoup de marchandises entre dans
le pays par la Malaisie
et ensuite que vont devenir ces
bouteilles
[Musique]
on les confise et on fait des analyses
pour savoir si c'est du vrai ou du faux
on les vend aux enchères pour le compte
de l'État
on le détruit
mais il y a pire que le whisky frelaté
ce sont ces petites pilules roses
le yaba le cauchemar des douaniers le
yabas et la drogue du pauvre chimique
addictive et toxique plus méchante que
le crack ce serait la drogue la plus
dangereuse au monde
je revois soudain la mise en scène de la
police
c'était du yaba que revendait les deux
trafics et le pire et qu'il n'y a rien
de plus facile à fabriquer
sont entrés dans le pays
il suffit d'en extraire les amphétamines
pour fabriquer le yaba
les médicaments contre la grippe sont
autorisés et la fabrication du yaba est
très simple
nous ont montré le processus de
fabrication
c'est très facile ça peut même se faire
dans une camionnette
de l'autre côté de la cloison ne pas
donc fait comme chez lui et se lance
dans une recette d'un autre genre
là je vais préparer une omelette à la
vapeur avec des herbes
c'est le chef douanier qui m'a donné la
recette
c'est vous qui lui avez appris oui
maintenant il fait partie de notre
équipe il faut qu'il sache cuisiner et
quand les autres douaniers sont trop
fatigués c'est nos pas donc qui nous
préparent
je les aime bien nos padons et son
cameraman
ils n'ont pas peur et se comportent bien
quand on est en mission
[Musique]
on augmente le feu pendant 10 secondes
1 2
ok
[Musique]
voyons voir
verdict c'est réussi
à l'autre bout de la vie de notre
journaliste de presse écrite s'offre lui
aussi une petite pause au commissariat
nous sommes dans la cuisine du
commissariat
les journalistes et la police
travaillent souvent ensemble
on travaille un peu en famille
donc tous les journalistes on vient
manger et boire un verre ici
c'est normal quand vous allez chez
quelqu'un il vous invite à manger
[Musique]
et derrière vous qui sont les gens en
photo sur le poster
ce sont les criminels les plus
recherchés
[Musique]
vous avez le montant de la prime pour
qui va l'interpeller comme aux
États-Unis ouais c'est pareil
mise à prix pour les plus recherchés
. justement une interpellation est dans
l'air
[Musique]
toi ne se presse pas il suit le 4x4 de
la police sans savoir ce qui se trame
c'est pas exactement où on va on sait
juste qu'il cherche à arrêter des
dealers
le
plus gros bidonville de Bangkok
aucune tension palpable dans les ruelles
toi en boîte le pas
l'arrestation va presque avoir lieu au
ralenti
moi avec mes enfants
montre-moi ça s'il te plaît
quelques jeunes qui traînent le plus âgé
tient ce qui ressemble à une pipe à yaba
et les policiers sortent leur mode
la pipe était en fait une sarbacane mais
les deux jeunes se font quand même
embarquer
retour au commissariat les policiers ne
rentrent pas bredouille de leur descente
dans le bidonville mais ils se sont
attaqués à un tout petit gibier on n'a
pas trouvé de drogues sur ces deux
prétendus dealers le plus âgé part pour
une analyse d'urine
l'échantillon fait apparaître un seul
trait rouge c'est un consommateur de
Yama
depuis longtemps oui
tu t'es déjà fait arrêter oui c'est la
deuxième fois
et voilà encore une interview
interférent en pleine procédure
judiciaire interview d'un suspect
menottes au poignet
l'accusé est un jeune paumé la ferme n'a
aucune envergure mais Toa on voit quand
même un papier
je viens de t'envoyer l'article et les
photos sur l'arrestation des dealers
ce type d'arrestation illustre
parfaitement la volonté politique de
répression du trafic de drogue
[Musique]
faire du chiffre pour combattre la
criminalité certaines polices
occidentales tombent dans les mêmes
travers
[Musique]
pas facile de démêler les points communs
et les différences entre ici et là bas
entre la Thaïlande et la France
un livre va m'aider à y voir plus clair
et à jeter des passerelles c'est un
polar bien sûr
[Musique]
Bangkok 8 signé par John Burdette un
anglais de Bangkok
[Musique]
il est presque minuit et demi l'heure où
le grand jeu atteint son paroxysme la
volonté des hommes timides qui ont dit
non toute la soirée et sapés par
l'alcool et les avances de fille à deux
minutes
avec une habileté consommée les filles
construisent un univers de rêve dans
l'esprit de l'occidental
elles aussi ont leur fantasmes trouvez
le pharaon qui les entretiendra jusqu'à
la fin de leur jour
est lui-même un pharaong c'est-à-dire un
occidental mais ce n'est pas un touriste
de passage
John Burdet avait choisi l'Asie et
c'était installé comme avocat d'affaires
à Hong Kong et puis c'est l'acide du
business nouveau métier nouvelle ville
le voici auteur de polar à Bangkok
depuis que j'ai refermé son livre une
question me trotte dans la tête les
hommes qu'il décrit passe d'une femme à
l'autre pas un seul né fidèle
réalité ou fiction
j'ai appris que les hommes ici en
Thaïlande trompaient beaucoup les femmes
oui c'est plus ou moins accepté
mais de temps en temps la femme
n'accepte pas au point de couper le sexe
de son homme
ça arrive souvent oui oui en fait il y a
une histoire très très connue d'un
policier un agent de police qui a trompé
sa femme sa femme a coupé sa son sexe et
au lieu d'être en colère il a dit ça y
est je vais être moine et
je suis plus intéressé dans les femmes
je vais avoir le pain pour le reste de
ma vie
bon on va dire que c'est une exception
qui confirme la règle
en colère avec son son mari elle a coupé
son pénis elle a attaché à un ballon
qui a passé partout
[Musique]
quand il est arrivé en ville et qui
s'est lancé dans l'écriture John
imaginait des intrigues sanglantes des
poursuites entre police et mafia
[Musique]
je pense à écrire un polar parce que il
est pas là sont populaires et un peu là
policier basé ici à Bangkok mais après
que j'ai passé quelques semaines en
causant avec les filles de bas qui sont
complètement franches et elles veulent
pas mentir parce que pour elle si on
monte c'est de mauvaise crame alors elle
donne toute l'histoire de leur vie et
j'ai réalisé c'est ça le roman c'est pas
les polices c'est les filles de bar qui
ont vraiment ce qu'il faut pour pour une
histoire
[Musique]
les filles de bar les prostituées
Bangkok a une réputation sulfureuse
quand la nuit tombe c'est une autre
ville qui se réveille John va me servir
de guide pour les quartiers chauds
prenez le métro aérien et descendez à
Nana ça ne s'invente pas
un quartier rouge à tous les sens du
terme difficile de venir ici pour autre
chose il y a des bars à hôtesse à tous
les numéros
[Applaudissements]
il est 20 heures la soirée commence
doucement
[Musique]
c'est un massage un peu
John n'a pas l'air de s'offusquer de
cette exploitation sexuelle il sait que
ses filles viennent de familles pauvres
mais ils ne les plint pas il les admire
pour moi elle sent des héroïques
parce qu'elle vend le corps pour le
fameux c'est pas qu'elle s'attend à ce
qu'elles vont être riche normalement
c'est simplement pour donner à manger à
la famille
[Musique]
John n'imagine pas que ses go-go girls
puissent faire autre chose en tout cas
la prostitution semble admise la pignon
sur rue et l'ambiance est presque bonne
enfant
je m'imaginais un terrain dangereux une
mine de faits divers
et je me retrouve dans une galerie
marchande où le sexe est une routine
je vérifie quand même avec John s'il n'y
a pas parfois quelques années crush
elles ont des astuces comme ça comme je
sais pas mettre quelque chose dans le
verre pour endormir les les parents
prendre leur argent il y a des histoires
comme ça il y a des histoires mais c'est
très très rare et normalement c'est pas
les vrais filles de bas qui font ça
c'est les filles freelance clique qu'on
voit dans la rue qui n'ont pas de bas
qui trouve une occasion où elles peuvent
voler les choses oui mais normalement
c'est pendant qu'il dort
il faut pas avoir peur il y a rien à
faire peur ici non pas du tout donc vous
voyez tous les Français
et c'est vrai qu'ils ont l'air content
ces pharaongues au bras de beauté
dénudés dont certaines pourraient être
leur fille
au bout de la nuit les billets passeront
demain en main plusieurs milliards de
dollars par an
le tourisme sexuel est de loin la
première source de devise de la
Thaïlande et je comprends mieux
maintenant le calme qui règne dans ses
ruelles
[Applaudissements]
les Pharaons doivent se sentir à l'aise
c'est bon pour les affaires d'ailleurs
la police veille au grain
[Musique]
en général il ne se passe pas grand
chose ici
les seuls problèmes ce sont les
touristes qui ont trop bu ou bien ceux
qui ne veulent pas payer
on appelle cela la police de proximité
je suis du Montana vous savez l'état des
cowboys
ça va aujourd'hui tu as presque tout
vendu la patrouille s'informe avec un
vendeur ambulant tu n'as plus rien mais
non je n'ai même pas vendu la moitié
s'il se passe quelque chose tu nous
préviens d'accord
de belles images pour ma caméra
dans ses romans John est moins en génie
il montre comment la police raquette les
quartiers chauds
[Musique]
tout va bien
et tu as beaucoup de clients ce soir
comment comprendre sinon que les
policiers passent devant toutes ces
créatures sans rien dire
en Thaïlande la prostitution est
théoriquement illégale
dans les faits la patrouille protège la
poule aux oeufs d'or
elle aurait aussi de quoi sévir dans les
rues voisines ici les marques se vendent
à prix d'amis montre t-shirt DVD les
classiques de la contrefaçon
même les fameuses pilules bleues ont
leur sœur jumelles le pharaon n'est pas
à l'abri d'une panne
du Viagra et ça y est une différence de
prix ça coûte combien ça
450 battes 11 euros pour le faux viagra
25 euros pour le vrai qui de toute façon
est sur mon faux lieux aussi il faut se
méfier des apparences avant de coque
la ville est un décor où il est facile
de se perdre
depuis que je m'intéresse au monde de la
nuit j'ai décalé mes horaires et ça va
très bien à son pet mon chauffeur
il n'y a pas beaucoup de circulation
aujourd'hui non il y a pas beaucoup de
trafic c'est chouette
il est 11h seulement
c'est un gros problème tous ces bouchons
à Bangkok c'est vrai parfois j'ai faim
et j'ai besoin de m'arrêter pour manger
ou aller aux toilettes et vous vous êtes
bloqués dans votre taxi et oui
vous avez déjà eu un accident
qui vous est rentré dedans
oui le conducteur avait bu du whisky ou
de la bière je sais pas
c'est un message alors dites-moi
pourquoi vous avez collé ces billets
[Musique]
si on vous pique votre voiture on est
riche
dans mon travail
en collant ses billets dans ma voiture
j'aurais plus de clients et donc plus
d'argent
si vous voulez vous pouvez me donner 500
euros
et je colle le billet
je rigole je vous donne 5 euros d'accord
et vous mettez là
ce matin toi mon ami journaliste du
Daily News m'a donné rendez-vous au
siège de la police de la circulation
avoir la taille du bâtiment on se doute
qu'il y a des embouteillages à Bangkok
même le roi paye de sa personne
à l'intérieur Toha et ses collègues
faits diversifiés ont leur salle de
permanence
donc c'est ici que vous venez travailler
c'est ça
[Musique]
c'est un bureau mis à la disposition des
journalistes
on voit toutes les caméras de
surveillance dans Bangkok
simplement pour éviter soi-même les
bouchons
et en attendant la prochaine actu cette
petite salle blafarde sert de bureau à
taux
vous faites ce métier depuis quand
êtes-vous un journaliste c'est ma
troisième année au fait divers
voilà ma carte de presse j'ai toujours
sur moi
avant c'était écrit fait divers dessus
maintenant c'est services administratifs
car quand les gens voient fait divers
ils ont peur et c'est plus difficile
pour nous de travailler
je me demande quel est le niveau des
salaires ici en Thaïlande
vous par exemple vous gagnez combien en
moyenne
aujourd'hui au Daily News je gagne
environ 10 000 bahts par mois
tout cela dépend du nombre d'articles il
y a aussi les primes
400 euros l'équivalent du salaire moyen
mais seulement les bons moments
l'effet diversifié ne sont pas des
seigneurs mais plutôt des ouvriers de
l'info
[Musique]
toi viens d'avoir un tuyau
rendez-vous 43 soyons dans un petit
commissariat de quartier
l'affaire des fœtus vient de rebondir
le commissaire d'illock a été coriace
l'un des fossoyeurs vient de se mettre à
table
s'est mis à parler il a reconnu tout de
suite qu'il entreposait des sacs
à
nous a conduit jusqu'à elle
on l'a arrêté on a tous saisi
on a trouvé du matériel d'avortement et
des matelas ensanglantés
ils ont tous les trois été arrêtés et
incarcérés
puis ils ont été libérés sous caution et
maintenant ils attendent leur procès
le mieux c'est d'aller au temple
[Musique]
le commissaire ditloc lui aussi est un
ami de la presse il va nous arranger une
interview avec l'un des suspects
ice le fossoyeur a été remis en liberté
avant le procès
faute de mieux il est retourné
travailler au temple des fœtus
il était anti shirt jaune sur la photo
vous saviez que ce que vous faisiez
était illégal
pitié des bébés
je ne voulais pas que les gens les
jettent dans les canaux ou à la poubelle
c'était mieux qu'il soit au temple tous
ensemble
et vous étiez payé combien
200 bahts par sac
[Musique]
c'était une façon de gagner de l'argent
oui mais c'était aussi une bonne action
pour ses fœtus
c'est un moral de brûler des bébés
[Musique]
ça me donne la chair de poule rien que
d'en parler
en faisant ça je pensais prendre soin de
ses bébés et éviter que leurs âmes
vagabondes
vous avez peur d'aller en prison
[Musique]
oui j'ai peur
mais j'estime avoir fait de mon mieux
pour ces bébés vous pensez qu'il va être
condamné je ne pense pas il n'est accusé
que d'avoir dissimulé les corps il ne
devrait pas avoir une peine trop lourde
et il a tué personne
Clémence ou ses vérités pour le
fossoyeur
l'audience est prévue pour la semaine
prochaine
je connaîtrai donc le verdict avant mon
départ
je remonte avec tôt la fréquence de la
police vient de grésiller toi n'a pas
tout compris mais quelque chose vient de
se passer sur la ligne de bus 187
[Musique]
nous y sommes en moins d'un quart
d'heure Toa va pêcher des infos
c'est incroyable vous avez tous un
couteau
le chauffeur a eu la présence d'esprit
de dérouter son bus et d'aller se garer
en plein devant une antenne de police
les passagers sont encore dans le bus
enfin ceux qui n'avaient pas de couteau
les autres ont été livrés sur un plateau
deux bandes rivales à droite des ados en
uniforme scolaire
à gauche d'autres ados ceci ont été
menottés avec leurs chemises
[Musique]
j'ai failli me prendre un coup de
couteau dans la jambe
au début j'ai gentiment demandé aux
jeunes de me remettre son couteau mais
il ne voulait pas et là
il a carrément essayé de me planter le
couteau dans la jambe comme ça
ce policier en tremblant encore
où est-ce que vous êtes allé boire
pourquoi tu n'étais pas en cours
en finissait à midi
ces jeunes sont les élèves de deux
instituts techniques concurrents
pas vraiment un profil de racaille
pourquoi ces jeunes se bagarrent
à mon avis c'est pour se rendre
intéressant
et faire parler de leur école
ces affrontements c'est pour frimer
auprès de leurs amis et montrer aux plus
jeunes qui sont courageux
il y a plusieurs causes des fois c'est
même pour une fille
ils sont ses couteaux
dénoncez-vous vite
les policiers ont haussé le ton même les
couteaux les plus longs retrouvent
soudainement leur propriétaire est-ce
par respect de l'autorité ou parce que
c'est bad boys savent pertinemment qui
ne risquent pas la prison ils sont
mineurs
[Musique]
toi reste blasé il n'en est pas à son
premier clash de lycéen c'est un fait
divers récurrent
[Musique]
et qui parfois va jusqu'à l'homicide
premier septembre 2010 deux lycéens pour
chasse en outre toujours cette rivalité
entre campus technologique la DO traquée
se réfugie dans un bus ces deux
poursuivants tirent plusieurs balles
perdus atteignent un petit garçon de 9
ans
il y laissera la vie
[Musique]
hymne national et lever des couleurs la
journée commence au quartier général de
la police
[Musique]
Doha a rendez-vous avec un grand compte
lieutenant général pompatte Chaya Poun
monsieur guerre des campus à
l'état-major cheveux ras et visage
burinés il n'a pas l'air très commode
et pourtant il a un discours de
compassion envers ces jeunes qui jouent
du couteau ou du pistolet
les fauteurs de troubles sont issus de
famille pauvres ou éclatés
ils ont souvent un sentiment
d'infériorité par rapport aux autres
jeunes
ce problème de gang d'étudiants me tient
à cœur
je voulais vraiment faire quelque chose
mais mes supérieure m'ont dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de moyens
alors j'ai décidé de mettre 60 000 bahts
par mois de mes économies personnelles
en tout ce programme va me coûter 2
millions de bahts
on a du mal à imaginer la même chose en
France aux États-Unis
[Musique]
je vais voir sur place à quoi sont
employés les derniers personnels du
lieutenant général
institut technologique de Patou moines
devant le campus une voiture de police
bien visible deux policiers à l'entrée
et un gadget technologique qui a dû
coûter cher au lieutenant général une
bande de reconnaissance digitale
[Musique]
les étudiants pointent avec le doigt
aujourd'hui tout est calme
mais il ne faut pas s'y tromper les
ennemis héréditaires sont à l'autre bout
de la rue
ceux de l'Institut technologique du tan
eux ont eu droit à un portique
électromagnétique comme à l'aéroport là
aussi des agents de faction
ils doivent tous signer le registre en
entrant comme ça on sait exactement qui
se trouve dans l'établissement
pour alimenter son article Toa va
organiser une petite discussion entre
jeunes et policiers
on veut vous aider à améliorer votre
image
car la société vous a à l'oeil
si on ne parle de vous que quand vous
vous battez la société vous méprisera
encore plus
à l'époque de nos parents les bagarres
ça existait déjà
eu
en 40 ans il y en a eu au moins une
centaine
il faut que ça change aujourd'hui
vous même vous vous êtes déjà battus
on essaie de pas rentrer dans leur jeu
on les évite
c'est pas nous c'est les autres avec un
discours pareil la guerre des campus
n'est pas prête de s'éteindre
[Musique]
il faut dire quand Thaïlande les adultes
ne donne pas l'exemple le pays est au
bord de la guerre civile depuis
plusieurs années la Thaïlande se déchire
entre chemise jaune la droite
nationaliste des chemises rouges la
gauche populaire cet après-midi les
rouges font une démonstration de force
l'événement est politique mais c'est Toa
le fait diversifier qui couvre pour le
Daily News
[Musique]
les chemises rouges ne sont pas
communistes mais réclament un meilleur
partage des richesses il critiquent le
gouvernement et même le roi
en face les chemises jaunes défendent le
statu quo et les classes dirigeantes
tout en jouant sur la fibre nationaliste
les voici en plein sitting
[Musique]
non pas donc notre reporter télé fait
une apparition des journalistes suivent
de près le face à face
chemise rouge contre chemise jaune il y
a eu 91 morts au printemps dernier et il
suffirait d'une étincelle pour que
l'incendie reparte
le feu couvre la Thaïlande d'en haut et
la Thaïlande d'en bas
cette tension sociale se cristallise
aussi sur la route
décidément c'est au volant que la
Thaïlande révèle son vrai visage quel
est ce nouveau fait divers lié à la
circulation
tout est parti d'une photo il est minuit
le 27 décembre devant sa voiture
seulement amoché une jeune fille de
bonne famille envoie un sms sur son
smartphone
cette photo presque insolite fait
exploser Facebook
en une seule journée 180 000 personnes
viennent t'y crier leur révolte
pourquoi cette colère toi va me donner
les clés
police de la circulation toi et à ses
entrées mais nous ressortons sur le
parking
c'est la voiture de la fille qui a causé
l'accident
à côté une autre épave celle-ci a
visiblement fait des tonneaux
les victimes ont été éjectées par là
[Musique]
la jeune femme au SMS a percuté ce
minibus avec sa voiture et je vais m'en
rendre compte sur les lieux de
l'accident
c'est elle qui est en tort
nous prenons la route de l'aéroport une
rocade suspendue au-dessus d'une autre
autoroute
une semaine après les traces de freinage
sont encore là la jeune femme conduisait
trop vite devant elle le minibus et le
percute par l'arrière
la collision a eu lieu la
puis ils ont glissé le long du parapet
à bord du minibus 14 passagers des
étudiants avec leur professeur de retour
d'un colloque
et les passagers ils ont été éjectés
le 27 immobilier un peu plus loin en
percutant un poteau
et les corps ont été projetés en
contrebas
une chute de 15 mètres le bilan sera
lourd c'est cette caméra là qui a filmé
oui
23h30 le crash en un éclair
le minibus part en toupie et vient
heurter le pylône de la caméra
une secousse les passagers viennent
d'être éjectés
[Musique]
en contrebas les ambulances bloquent le
trafic embouteillage monstre
émotion générale
[Musique]
un cadavre est resté accroché au tablier
du pont
8 sacs blancs viennent vite saigner les
secouristes posent pour les photographes
huit morts un neuvième décédera à
l'hôpital
au dessus la jeune femme envoie ses SMS
[Musique]
que les médias et les autorités
voulaient éviter débruiter l'affaire ils
ont très vite arrêté de parler de
l'accident il a fallu que les gens
expriment leur mécontentement et exigent
que les autorités fassent leur travail
cette jeune fille ne devait pas
bénéficier d'un traitement de faveur à
cause de son nom parce qu'elle était
issue d'une famille noble
[Musique]
noble et mineur la jeune fille avait
emprunté la voiture et conduisait sans
permis
la justice va-t-elle l'épargner
va-t-elle fuir à l'étranger
pour faire taire les rumeurs la date de
son audition est communiquée à la presse
devant une meute de journaliste elle
arrive au commissariat avec sa mère
c'est ce qui s'appelle jouer la
transparence
derrière la vitre la jeune auracharne
c'est son nom ne peut pas échapper au
regard devant des millions de
téléspectateurs elle reconnaît les faits
signe sa déposition et quitte les lieux
en jouant des coudes
elle a reçu des menaces de mort mais ne
semble pas réaliser ce qui lui arrive
-t-on là où est-ce qu'elle va aller
elle va aller dans un centre pour mineur
de lincamp elle va rester là-bas c'est
ça c'est le centre qui décidera
elle a perdu le contrôle de sa voiture
oui c'est ça
les médias allez allez reculer s'il vous
plaît
allez reculer
la Thaïlande n'enferme pas les mineurs
cette jeune fille bien née échappera à
la prison mais pas à l'avant dicte
populaire
pour calmer les esprits les parents
indéminiseront les familles de victimes
mais c'est la société tout entière qui
paye le prix fort pour ses morts de la
route pour éviter le pire
il suffit parfois d'intervenir à temps
c'est le travail des ambulanciers comme
ami à vous
il m'a pris avec lui pour quelques
heures
sa première urgence n'en est pas une
on va parler
ce jeune motard vient de chuter sur la
chaussée
vous pouvez lever le bras ça vous fait
mal il n'a même pas éteint sa cigarette
il a pourtant la clavicule déboîtée
regarde sa clavicule
c'est pas normal
ça va tu vas pouvoir conduire il faut
aller à l'hôpital
pas difficile de comprendre les raisons
de sa chute
j'aurais besoin de sable il y a de
l'huile sur la chaussée
attention roulez doucement ça glisse
[Musique]
trop tard un deuxième scooter a glissé
sur la plaque d'huile
c'est le deuxième en 10 minutes
[Musique]
l'accidenté repart sans gants son
t-shirt et son casque
il y a chaque année plus de 7000 morts
sur les routes de Thaïlande c'est près
de deux fois plus qu'en France
[Musique]
pour ne pas finir lui-même dans une
ambulance Annie avoue à un truc il
conduit sous le double regard de Bouddha
et de sa petite caméra
dès que j'entends une urgence sur la
radio
j'allume la caméra
et je filme comme ça
quand j'arrive sur les lieux d'un
accident je filme tout
on se sert de ces images pour la
formation des futurs ambulanciers
[Musique]
voici les images d'Annie à vous on
reconnaît sa petite statue de Bouddha à
gauche du tableau de bord
ce matin-là il y a un gros attroupement
dans le quartier de pracanau
la conductrice d'un scooter vient de
passer sous un autobus
[Musique]
elle est passée sous la roue avant ou
arrière du bus
la jeune femme a été décapitée une
vision d'horreur qui contraste avec le
calme de la foule
voyeurisme ou fatalisme
vous la connaissiez oui c'est une de mes
étudiantes on s'était rencontrés ici par
hasard
on avait fini de discuter on s'était
même dit au revoir
[Musique]
étrange elle est morte sous ses yeux il
reste souriant peut-être se dit-il que
tel était son karma
peut-être la croyance en la
réincarnation vient-elle dédramatiser
les drames
[Musique]
Annie à vous lui même il croit très fort
à la réincarnation
il faut dire que son employeur est un
peu particulier
c'est une fondation bouddhiste
Juan cataniu en taille ensemble soyons
solidaires
à première vue on dirait un temple comme
un autre
mais à l'intérieur les bénévoles sont au
travail
voici comment la fondation se finance
prenez la famille wonkhaï des donateurs
comme tant d'autres
contre un billet de 100 bahts on leur
remet un petit papier en rouge
[Musique]
à l'autre bout de la pièce de longues
boîtes en pilées ce sont des cercueils
vides
pas de bois précieux ce sont les
cercueils les plus simples
pour ceux qui n'ont rien
monsieur wonkhaï colle son nom une bonne
action pour toute la famille
nous venons environ une fois par mois
faire un don pour un cercueil on vient
le dimanche car mon mari ne travaille
pas
et voilà comment la Fondation peut
offrir des cérémonies funéraires aux
indigents
vous savez si les fondations comme les
nôtres n'existaient pas ce serait au
gouvernement de faire ce travail
en Thaïlande beaucoup de fondations
viennent en aide au plus démunis je ne
peux pas imaginer mon pays sans ces
organismes humanitaires
le pays repose sur trois piliers la
nation la religion et la royauté
avec les dons des fidèles la Fondation
salariée aussi un croque-mort jamelon 67
ans une figure locale le voici en train
d'arrangler les visiteurs il faut
allumer trois bâtons d'ensemble 3 bâtons
d'encens
on dirait que le contact de la mort lui
donne de l'énergie
je peux ramasser jusqu'à 4 ou 5 cadavres
par jour
ça peut aller jusqu'à 10 je fais ça pour
améliorer mon karma
[Musique]
quelles sont les causes des décès il y a
les victimes d'accidents des gens qui se
font tirer dessus ou poignarder et il y
a aussi des suicides par pendaison ou
avec des médicaments
les suicides il y en avait beaucoup
moins quand jamelon a commencé de
ramasser les cadavres il y a 30 ans
mais depuis la grande crise de 1997 les
statistiques sont implacables le taux de
suicide a presque doublé
il est aujourd'hui de 15 pour 100000
habitants la France est à 16
pour conjurer tout le malheur dont il
est témoin jamelon le croque-mort à un
truc
ces amulettes ne protègent de toutes
sortes de dangers
je n'en ai jamais acheté
arrête la religion où commence la
superstition
théoriquement les amulettes ne
s'achètent pas et se transmettent de
génération en génération
à deux pas du Palais Royal je vais
pourtant trouver un marché qui vend de
la chance en pendentif
pour les convaincus il y a là de quoi
devenir riche
éviter la stérilité
et même se protéger des armes à feu avec
ce bouddha usé qui se cache les yeux et
rendu cou les tireurs aveugles
très populaire me dit le marchand chez
les policiers et les malfrats
[Musique]
ce avec qui j'ai maintenant rendez-vous
aurait peut-être dû prendre un bon vieux
gilet par balle
il m'attendent au sixième étage de ce
complexe gouvernemental mais ils ne
seront pas très bavards
c'est cette femme en blouse blanche qui
parle pour eux
la star des médecins légistes en
Thaïlande elle est connue comme le loup
blanc et la même sa statue de cire au
musée Grévin local
[Musique]
avec ses mèches colorées on dirait une
chanteuse de variété c'est pourtant une
sommité de la médecine
sur ces images elle assiste l'armée dans
les provinces du Sud là-bas des
musulmans radicaux ont pris les armes
contre le pouvoir
relève les morts et aide aux enquêtes
quand elle passe à Bangkok elle
s'intéresse à des cas plus anciens
une balle
par où est-elle passée
ici derrière l'épaule
ça signifie que la balle qu'il l'a
touché à pénétrer la poitrine
et là-bas ce que vous voyez c'est un
crâne fracturé
ici
par pièce comme un puzzle
assassinat ou accident peu importe
aujourd'hui
c'est squelette n'ont même pas de nom et
porn type cherche tout simplement à les
identifier
dans ce cas par exemple
vous pouvez remarquer qu'il y a eu une
fracture réparer avec une plaque et des
vis
et là une autre pathologie regardez
c'est une personne qui a été trépanée on
peut en déduire qu'elle a dans le passé
subit une intervention chirurgicale du
cerveau
chaque jour deux à trois corps arrivent
ici si le décès est récent porte type
mais les photos sur son site
les internautes reconnaîtront peut-être
un proche
si le cadavre est décomposé alors il
faut reconstituer le visage porn type et
son équipe prennent le temps qu'il faut
[Musique]
tout le pays est sous le contrôle de la
police et la police veut faire
disparaître par la crémation non
seulement ses squelettes mais tous les
morts non identifiés dans les 5 à 10 ans
maximum
mais les corps qui sont ici dans notre
institut nous les conserverons jusqu'à
ce que nous puissions un jour les
identifier et les rendre à leurs proches
[Musique]
derrière chacun de ces squelettes il y a
une famille qui attend de faire son
deuil
[Musique]
dans chacun de ces cartons il y a un
mort qui attend de trouver le repos
[Musique]
dans la grande roue de l'existence la
mort n'est qu'une étape
97% des Thaïlandais sont bouddhistes
[Musique]
il y a plus de temples à Bangkok que
d'église à Paris et une autre différence
me saute aux yeux les fidèles sont
nombreux et plutôt jeunes
[Musique]
il croit au karma et font des offrandes
mais ils lisent aussi les journaux il y
a aussi des faits divers à l'intérieur
des monastères
sur cette photo un bonze en mauvaise
posture il fournissait des amphétamines
à une jeune toxicomane en échange de
faveur sexuel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour punir les brebis galeuses les
autorités religieuses ont créé une
police interne
[Musique]
curieux des moines qui jouent au flic
après de longues négociations ils
acceptent m'emmener sur une patrouille
première surprise les moines flics ont
pris des talkie-walkis les garder leur
propre
pour des masquer d'autres bronze
pourquoi choisir un marché parce que
c'est là que les tailles achètent leurs
offrandes
des fleurs de l'encens ou des sachets de
soupes qui seront déposés au temple ou
bien remis à des moines ambulants
c'est justement l'un de ces moines qui a
repéré la patrouille
[Musique]
il reçoit des offrandes et donne sa
bénédiction
rien de plus normal
[Musique]
mais l'instant d'après il reverse le
contenu de sa corbeille à cet homme en
t-shirt blanc la police religieuse fleur
l'arnaque mais ne bouge pas
la brigade a repéré un homme qui
pourrait bien être un faux moine
on ne va pas intervenir maintenant car
il y a des gens qui lui donnent des
offrandes
et ça on doit le respecter
et ça risque de provoquer des problèmes
si vous l'arrêtez maintenant
on en a déjà fait l'expérience ce sont
les marchands qui risquent de protester
ce qui les intéresse c'est de continuer
à vendre leur marchandises
la caméra elle peut s'approcher
[Musique]
et je comprends la combine l'homme au
t-shirt et lui-même un marchand de
fronde il récupère tout ce que lui donne
le faux moine et va le remettre en vente
ces deux-là ont inventé le mouvement
perpétuel
[Musique]
le faux moine repart en laissant
échapper son salaire
cette fois je suis repéré
le faubourg lui prend la fuite
il devait être de mèche avec le marché
c'était sûrement un faux moine un vrai
moine lui ne se serait pas enfui
raté pour cette fois mais la police
religieuse la désormais dans le
collimateur
ce que j'ai vu n'était qu'un petit
larcin mais la religion va aussi me
mettre sur la piste du banditisme
cette fois les moines ne sont pas en
cause mille côtoient les malfrats ou
plutôt il est à tout
temple de bangpra
si le tatouage est un art qui se
pratique au lancer
[Musique]
patum est un maître aujourd'hui à la
retraite
chaque jour 30 personnes se présentent
pour un tatouage gratuit et personnalisé
dans ce temple nous faisons des
tatouages depuis plus d'un siècle je
voyais déjà ça quand j'étais petit les
personnes qui viennent ici croient aux
bienfaits des tatouages à la protection
qu'ils apportent
le tigre est l'un des motifs les plus
populaires mais suivant la profession de
chacun certains animaux s'imposent
ce motif est un oiseau qui parle
l'oiseau sadicat
celui qui porte ce tatouage sera écouté
et cru à chaque fois qu'il prendra la
parole
c'est un tatouage que demande beaucoup
de commerçants
évidemment une question me brûle les
lèvres si toutes les corporations ont
leur animal fétiche alors ça veut dire
que certains criminels ou délinquants
passent aussi par ses mains expertes
des gens viennent vraiment se faire des
tatouages pour se protéger des balles
ils se font tatouer un ours ou un singe
l'ours parce qu'il a une peau très
épaisse et le singe Hanouman parce qu'il
est très puissant
certains se font tatouer trois ou quatre
motifs pour être sûr d'échapper aux
balles
[Musique]
je vais rester toute la journée en
embuscade mais il n'y aura pas de gibier
pour ma caméra pas de petits ou gros
voyou venus ce jour-là se faire tatouer
un singe ou un ours sur la poitrine il y
a pourtant un milieu et même une mafia
en Thaïlande
Hollywood ne s'y est pas trompé
les scénaristes ont tiré la matière d'un
blockbuster avec Nicolas Cage Bangkok
dangerous
[Musique]
dans la vraie vie les mafieux se cachent
comme dans tous les pays du monde il
fuient la caméra mais j'ai l'impression
qu'ils sont particulièrement
insaisissables ici
il y a trois fois plus d'homicides qu'en
France et les règlements de comptes sont
rarement élucidés pas de funérailles
avec limousine comme dans le parent
comme si une chape de plomb étouffait
les bruits des revolvers
[Musique]
c'est pas anti la star des médecins
légistes qui va me donner l'explication
de cet étrange silence
il y a énormément d'armes en circulation
en Thaïlande
c'est le ministère de l'Intérieur qui
délivre les autorisations et qui
contrôlent les permis de port d'armes
mais il y a énormément de corruption
et du coup les armes à feu les revolver
prolifèrent
on en voit partout
en plus on a des gangs mafieux et les
complices de ces gangs sont parfois des
policiers parfois des militaires
grave accusation lancée par un haut
fonctionnaire qui plus est porn type
dépend du ministère de la Justice
si cette collusion police mafia est
aussi répandue alors il est impossible
pour les journalistes d'enquêter sur les
plus gros faits divers
dernière visite à Chanel 3
j'ai rendez-vous avec un des visages de
la chaîne
caruna buckemsrie
vous avez fini pour aujourd'hui
presque oui je dois y retourner après le
sujet je lui pose d'emblée une question
simple
pouvez-vous nous parler d'un crime qui
vous a vraiment choqué
un fait divers qui m'a choqué oui celui
de cet enfant qui s'est fait tirer
dessus par des trafiquants de drogue
ça s'est passé il y a tout juste de moi
l'enfant était en voiture avec ses
parents et tout à coup de type leur
tirent dessus comme ça sans raison et
une balle a touché le gamin
et il est mort après avoir passé
plusieurs jours à l'hôpital et ça oui
vraiment ça a été un choc
encore un clash entre automobiliste
mais celui-ci va dévoiler
accidentellement un visage du grand
banditisme
décidément en Thaïlande tout commence et
tout finit sur le bitume
une simple queue de poisson a déclenché
une grosse opération
les deux frères sont les deux motards
d'irassibles qui n'ont pas aimé la queue
de poisson une balle perdue un enfant
mort et les voici promis ennemis public
numéro 1 la situation est confuse la
Sauvêtre filmée en direct
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais dehors l'un des deux frères vient
d'être rattrapés l'aîné le plus
dangereux
[Applaudissements]
paroles compromettante la caméra a tout
enregistré l'arrestation a fini en
exécution les policiers anticipent la
critique et insistent sur le pistolet
que porter le fugitif
la légitime défense
[Musique]
colère des défenseurs des droits de
l'homme une enquête est en cours
en attendant les policiers ont découvert
une cache chez le frère aîné
de l'héroïne et désenfhéamine pour plus
d'un million d'euros et tout un arsenal
l'homme aimé se mettre en scène un vrai
caïd
[Musique]
son frère est arrêté quelques jours plus
tard le voici avec son casque de motard
pour une reconstitution
c'est d'ici que tout est parti la queue
de poisson de la voiture et les tirs de
représailles un policier joue le rôle de
son frère
mais le frère survivant va aller plus
loin toujours sous les caméras il va
s'adresser au petit garçon mort d'une
balle perdue
je te demande pardon
je n'ai pas voulu ta mort
et je voudrais que tu me pardonnes
en Thaïlande la violence à fleurs sous
le sourire
il est l'heure pour moi de rentrer en
France mais avant de partir je m'étais
promis de rendre une dernière visite au
temple des fœtus
[Musique]
deux mois après le drame les gens
continuent à apporter des offrandes pour
ses petites âmes en voler
des vêtements des jouets et des peluches
tout ce qu'un bon karma peut apporter à
un enfant
le verdict est tombé pour sous Charles
fossoyeur 20 ans de prison au lieu de la
clémence annonçait
[Musique]
cette histoire m'aura marquée peut-être
plus que les autres
en tout cas j'en aurai plus appris sur
la Thaïlande avec les faits divers
qu'avec mon guide de voyage
coca sous sanglant les faits divers sont
comme l'inconscient d'un pays
ils m'ont dit de la Thaïlande tout ce
qu'elles n'osent pas savoir elle-même
sourire et violence mélangée
[Musique]